President Trump says he scrapped an
upcoming trip to London because the new
US embassy is a bad deal the president
was up late because just before midnight
the president tweeted quote reason I
canceled my trip to London is that I am
NOT a big fan of the Obama
administration having sold perhaps the
best located and finest embassy in
London for peanuts only to build a new
one in an off location for 1.2 billion
dollars bad deal wanted me to cut ribbon
no exclamation point well the new
embassy is located about two miles from
the old site it sits on the banks of the
River Thames Jonathan Vigliotti is
outside the new embassy Jonathan good
morning good morning this is the
so-called bad deal behind president
Trump's latest controversial tweet the
over 1 billion dollar US Embassy still
under construction sits on a man-made
hill it has its own moat and it's
considered one of the most secure places
in the world on paper and certainly in
person this fortress lives up to the
extreme security President Trump has
called for in the States but this
morning the president said he was not a
big fan and blamed President Obama for
the move but president Trump's facts are
off here that bad deal was actually made
by President George W Bush in 2008
president Trump's cancellation also
comes amid backlash over Prime Minister
Theresa Mays invitation for the
president's state visit many Londoners
have been angered by what they call
president Trump's divisive politics
Lenin mayor Sadiq Khan weighed in on
Twitter this morning saying Londoners
have made it clear that Donald Trump is
not welcomed however the president's
cancellation has no impact on that state
visit the offer still stands there is no
set date John Jonathan Vigliotti in
London thanks